Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode. And today is another
episode of Rawkode live where we explore
really cool cloud native and Kubernetes adjacent technologies
that will hopefully help make your developer and
operator lives a little bit easier.
Today, we're taking a look at a search
and analytics engine that promises, maybe that's a
strong word, we'll see what Francois says, But
promises sub second latency,
and it's obviously written in Rust, which obviously
makes it even more exciting for me to
take a look at today.
So let's jump over and meet today's guest,
Francois. Hello. Thank you for joining me. Hello,
David.
Please just take a moment and share a
little bit more information about you with the
audience.
Okay.
Hello,
David. Hello, everyone. Thank you very much for
inviting me.
I'm very happy, like, to talk about Quickwit,
obviously.
So what is Quickwit?
That's a company and a search engine. We
started it three years ago.
I'm one of the cofounder, and we are
we started it at free with Paul and
Adrian. Paul is in lives in Tokyo. Adrian
is in New York and living in Paris.
And
we are all engineers, and we
we
heard a lot of complaints about
Elasticsearch speeds, especially for big datasets
and especially in the observability space.
And
it happens that one of my cofounder, Paul,
created
many years ago a library called
written in Rust. And this is, like, an
equivalent of Lucene
in the Java world. So it's a search
library, but you it's not a
fully distributed search engine.
But at least you have the data structure
in it to make search fast.
And
this library
was really fast three years ago already.
And, like, when discussing
with Adrian and Paul, what we were
looking at at the space, and we we
said to ourselves, okay.
We can we can do something better. Maybe.
And,
I mean,
a search engine
distributed
that can be way, way faster or way
more efficient than Elasticsearch.
And when you when you start something like
this, you you you want to be at
least 10 times 10 times
cheaper or 10 times faster,
maybe 100 times
if possible.
And that was our goal.
And okay. So three years after, I'm here
to talk about it.
We just released
version
two version
zero dot seven
two weeks ago,
and we have some we we are starting
to have our big users
that are ingesting
hundreds of terabyte per days of logs,
and
it's really, really efficient. They
they divide it by five, their compute cost,
by
by the same number of their storage cost
their their storage cost.
So
we're we're very
happy for them,
and
we think that we can bring, like, a
lot of value
in the space of of the space.
I'm here to talk about it.
Awesome. Thank you so much.
Let's cover a couple of things that you've
mentioned then.
I've I've been a developer for a long
a long time, over twenty years now. And
everybody's always said Elasticsearch is amazing, but everybody
hates. And by everybody I'm gonna say I
and hopefully others. We hated the fact that
it was on the JVM. It's notoriously difficult
to to operate. It consumes a lot of
memory and CPU. It doesn't run well in
containers and on Kubernetes.
But people always said it would be impossible
to build it in any other language because
of Lucene.
And what you're saying now is that we
it's not impossible. We have Lucene available in
another language, Rust. I think there was even
a Go one as well at one point
and but I'm not sure what happened to
it. So that's that's awesome right off the
bat. Right? Just the fact that this library
now exists and allows people to be free
of the JVM, Elasticsearch, and other things and
still get that power that we get from
that type of search is awesome. Wonderful.
You then spoke a little bit about you
and your team building on Quickwit and sub
seconds is something we've said three times now.
You know,
why or like what are the use cases
people could be doing? You've you've mentioned observability.
Right? But Elasticsearch is obviously very broad in
this application. Is that true for Quickwit as
well? What do you see people using it
for?
Yeah. So that's that's a very good point.
So we chose to a subset of all
the search space. The search space is huge,
especially today with all the AI stuff.
So we chose a subset, like, the observability
space, but it's not only. It's append only
datasets.
It's coming from a choice that we of
architecture.
So very early on, we chose we chose
to
totally change the architecture of search
of our the search engine.
Like, Elasticsearch is based on a shared mapping
architecture. So all the data is on the
disk, on the local disk.
It's very fast. As you as you said,
it's it's a powerful engine.
It's
many many it has a a large community.
It's a great it's a great tool, really.
But
when you want to scale,
when you want to, like, separate concerns,
compute like, indexing stuff versus
search stuff,
it's really nice to start
separating compute storage.
And that's that's the starting point of Quickwit.
We wanted to decouple compute storage, to decouple
indexing and search,
and, like, seamlessly scale from one to
50 nodes for indexing and for such. Like,
in a a couple of seconds, you should
be able to do it without impacting anything,
without struggling with
yellow or head cluster.
I I used a lot Elasticsearch before, and
it was horrible
to operate.
I'm sure they improved that today, but at
that time, it was really horrible. And you
don't have this kind of mess when you
take a.
You start you you that is safe on
something like s three. You don't have any
issue with that with that.
Nice.
So I'm curious then. What
your background before you started working on on
Quickwit, were you already a Rust developer, or
is this your first exploration of writing Rust
code?
So for me, it was my first experience.
I was mainly a Python programmer and Java
programmer before.
Luckily
for us, my cofounder, Paul, who
created Tonti, was a very good REST developer.
So he let he led us the the
right way to code in Rust, and so
it was awesome because we improved
very fast. Like, the team the team was
able to improve their lot their skills.
So that was really precious to have him
in the team, of course.
But it was my first time in Rust,
and it was really painful at the beginning.
The the first three months were
very hard,
and then it was a revelation.
Like, no bug in production. We we we
at the very beginning of Quickwit, we made
a proof of concept of Quickwit,
the idea of separating compute and storage for
search. And it was based on the common
core demo. So common core is a dataset
with billions of web pages,
and we index everything
and put the data the index data on
s three. And you can go on common
like, we have a commoncall.Quickwit.i0
website where you can just search few things,
and we will return
a word cloud of the most probable combination
of words.
So if you start typing Obama is, you
we will give you, like, the all the
most common adjectives for Obama is something.
And
yeah. So and there was no bug.
Yes. There was one bug, but it was
in the Python code because we we have
to use Python for
some kind of
an analytic language
analytics
because we we were analyzing if we were
retrieving nouns or adjectives.
Mhmm. And the bug was there, but not
in our code. So it was really
a revelation, really. So I'm very happy to
code in Rust today.
Yeah.
Me too. I I pretty much write everything
in Rust by default now or TypeScript if
I have to do any sort of web
stuff. But
but even though I have been writing Rust
code for a while now, there's always that
weird lifetime bug or that I just don't
understand. Or when we get nested generics,
I end up just pulling my hair out.
And I I really actually spend more time
going deeper with these things, but I just
I've not had to deal with them often
enough to force myself to just learn it
properly.
I I'm in the same situation. This kind
of lifetime issues or trade
issues are really
that's horrible. I think it's a it's more
a problem of it's two variables. You have
too many
error
message is too complex. So maybe voice team
can improve that. I hope one day they
they would do. Yeah. The minute you just
you I don't wanna go into the weeds
of rest for everyone watching, but, you know,
once you start having, like, dynamic traits passed
around with late times, it's it's it's so
painful.
But that's
a lesson from another day.
Alright. Well, thank you for sharing all of
that. I'm really excited about this project. I
can't wait to actually see it and experiment
with it and play with it because I
think that everyone who has anything running in
production has a use case that Quickwit can
come in and help them with, and I
wanna try and show that to people today.
So the format for today's episode is we're
gonna run through the getting started gate like
we always do. And then Francois has a
demo where he's gonna show us a bit
more of a deeper use case for Quickwit.
Please remember, if you have any questions whatsoever,
you can drop them into the comments. And
that doesn't just mean now as we are
live. If you're watching this after the fact,
keep those comments coming, and I will always
pass them on to our guest to hopefully
get you the answer. No pressure, Francois, but
that means for the next twenty four months,
you always have to answer my emails and
a timely response.
That's alright.
Alright. Here is my terminal.
I also have
a browser
where we have the Quickwit homepage. So if
anyone wants to find this in their own
time, you can find us at quickwit.io.
We're gonna go straight to the quick start
guide.
Nice. So we're just gonna curl bash which
I'm always happy to do. Don't you worry.
Doesn't scare me whatsoever.
And this is gonna get us which I
assume is just a static binary because you've
written this thing in Rust and we should
be able to get started right away. That's
one of the other nice things. Like, when
you get a JVM artifact, a jar file,
it's just always like, well, what do I
do with this?
Awesome.
I'm gonna move this to here.
Two mod plus x Quickwit and
then run.
Okay.
So there's also docker image,
which is nice.
Is there a Helm chart? Just out of
curiosity. Like, if I wanna ship this into
production,
is Helm charts the best way for people
to you know, if anyone watches this and
goes, wow. That's amazing. I want it. Helm
chart. Is that what they do first?
Yes. So there there is a a ham
chart.
And, like, I I will make a demo
on it. So and it's available on the
GitHub repository.
Alright. Awesome.
So in order to get this Powerhouse of
a search engine running, we do Quickwit run.
I don't need to talk. So I gotta
work this out easy.
Uh-oh.
Yeah. I was expecting that. So as as
you move, like, as you move, like, the
binary outside the the directory,
you need to specify
you can specify, like,
the config file.
It it needs to find a a config
file. That that's it. Oh, that's alright. I'll
I'll take the ownership of that one. So
okay. I didn't realize we had a Quickwit
data directory,
and I don't have my alias configured. Let's
just do this.
We have a config file. So I'm gonna
take a really look at that. I'm always
curious about configuration.
We got YAML.
And
Vexors and that's it. Okay.
We'll maybe take a look at that in
a bit more detail later when we start
asking some of the questions about what's actually
happening with the system here.
But if we run this as it is,
we get a whole bunch of log output.
This output looks like the tracing library. Would
that be Exactly. Yes. We are always using
it a lot. Yeah. I think everybody uses
the tracing library for for output these days.
It's it's it's wonderful.
Alright. Do I have a search engine?
So what you can open yes. You can
open your web browser.
Like, you can you can click on Oh,
yeah. Just above there is a link if
you want.
Alright. So we just got a little bit
of There is a solution. There is also
a small user interface, so it can be
nice to just
hit the root
URL.
Yeah. That's it. Nice. Wasn't expecting that, but
I'm happy.
So you can you can get the list
of indexes
on the left and here.
So out the box then, Quickwit is sending
its own logs to itself. Is that correct?
Not by default. So what you can do
very simply is to send the traces.
Like, traces are more powerful, so we so
if
you use, like, two
environment variables, you can send tray Quickwit traces
into Quickwit.
But that's very common setup.
I can give you the environment variables
if you want. But so that you can
have something already
in your
Oh, so it just creates the indexes up
front, but there's not actually any any data
at the moment. Exactly.
Or indices, I guess, I should say. Correct
myself.
Although it says the index is here, I'll
just take it. We'll go with that. Alright.
So let's cover this up with the terminology,
and I'm sure this is covered in the
docs. But, you know, let's go off script
a little bit. We pulled up this UI.
We've got the query editor, but we don't
have any data yet. So we have cluster
information and config here, and we can see
notes. So this thing is obviously horizontally scalable.
We'll talk about that later.
We've got clusters,
node info. We've got the API documentation, which
is always nice to have embedded, and we
have indices and indexes.
So what is the vocabulary that people need
to understand when they're working with Quickwit? What
is it index in a specific
implementation?
Yeah. So like in Elasticsearch,
you define
you you don't have tables like in SQL.
You create your index and you put, like,
your JSON documents in it. That's it. And
for each index, you have to define a
mapping.
So if you if you click, for example,
on the trace index here,
you
have a small summary, and then you can
go to the
dot mapping tab
where you will see that we will prepare
fine, like, all the fields needed
for
a trace model.
We base this mapping on the open telemetry
model because it's
commonly used.
We did the same for logs.
And here, you have a bunch of fields,
like, the same way as Elasticsearch is a
bit different.
There
is one big difference
on the mapping part because
one thing where Quickwit is quite powerful is
on the part.
You don't you don't have to define your
schema. You can just define one timestamp field,
and everything can be dynamic.
And you don't you you won't have the
issues like
conflicting types, for example, because we we distinguish
in the in our database. We distinguish, like,
integers,
strings. If if there are two type different
types, that's fine.
We can agree do aggregations on different types,
so there's no there's no problem, no conflicts.
So it can be very flexible
for it and especially for in the log
space where you don't know
your schema, it's it's pretty efficient. So here
for OpenTelemetry,
you have the full mapping,
can be useful. And for some mapping, for
example, if you look at attributes,
like, resource attributes, if you go down in
you just have to go down in the
map.
You
if you look for resource attributes, you will
see that it's a JSON field. And the
fact that if it's JSON, you can put
everything in it. Like, for example, links, it's
an array of JSON.
And you can put every field in it,
and you will be able to search through
them.
Oh, very nice.
Alright. Yeah. I was gonna ask about that
if I've ever been had to have a
schema. So I like the the flexibility that
it can just pull in stuff. Can I
mark an index as strict and that it
won't accept anything that doesn't directly
Exactly?
Okay. Yeah. Exactly. You you you have this
strict mode to avoid.
Oh. You're a big a big mess. Alright.
Awesome.
Nice.
Alright. We have a comment
saying hello. First time catching one of these
live. Well, thank you for joining us. If
you're saying if you want to see with
Quickwit or you have a question, please feel
free to follow-up in the comments.
Alright. So we got index settings, search settings,
retention,
splits,
and sources.
So with retention settings, I'm assuming
we can configure the time to live on
the record so we can auto expire them
after twenty four hours, four days,
whatever. Would that be correct?
Yes. That's more or less correct.
What we do
so we now we I need to enter
a bit how Quickwit index things to explain
this.
When you push documents
into Quickwit,
Quickwit will create what we call splits. So
it's
a small piece of index, basically.
In the it's independent,
and Quickwit will just create
a bunch of splits, maybe a few hundreds
or thousands.
And, like, it's a big equivalent of segment
in Elasticsearch.
And and Quickwit will also do some merging
to make search more efficient. So if you
have 10 small split, it will merge them
into one.
And
what people generally
do
is they will just
remove those splits if they are
older than thirty days.
So we don't use
it's not a per document retention setting. It's
a split it's on on the split.
So it's really efficient. We don't have to
rebuild the entire split if we want to
remove only 10 documents, for example.
And
generally, it's sufficient because you would have
a few split per days. And
once once they are over
older than thirty days, it will be deleted.
They will be deleted.
Okay.
Are there,
you know, any cardinality limits or concerns
when we start to index things within Quickwit?
Like,
if I have a
a million or 10,000,000 or a billion series,
like, have you stress tested it to that
kind of level?
Billion what? Bit documents?
Yeah. So
when typically,
when you when you index stuff, right, you're
you're indexing on certain properties within the document.
And then if I write one document where
there's a
a value of country and then I insert
a thousand countries,
we have a cardinality of a Okay. Okay.
And then if that explodes, then the query
performance can essentially be crippled
because the cardinality is too high for the
indexes to optimize for. Is that something
that's been challenged or fixed with with Quickwit?
So, generally,
with search engine, the nice thing is that
you have those inverted index
indexes.
So it's really,
searching
to find the needle in the stack is
working pretty well.
What's happening is that if you have a
high cardinality fields,
indexing is a bit slower.
You will see that it is it will
get it will get slower because we will
like, the index would be bigger, so you
need to allocate more more memory for that.
But it will work really well. Like,
I tested, like, I tested with fields, with
millions with the cardinality in millions,
more than millions, 10 millions, and, like, there
is no issue doing that. Like, a search
engine
is can handle this pretty
pretty efficiently.
Yeah. And I think the reason I asked
is that, obviously, we have got the index
settings, and then we've got the retentions.
And if I've got a low retention threshold
where the index has to be purged
regularly with a high cardinality, I assume those
could be conflicting.
But I don't wanna create problems that don't
exist, so we'll come back for that
later on or another time.
I think
we should create an index
and
write some data, which I'll assume
is where this is going to go. Yeah.
So
in order to create an index, we need
to send
an index con oh, we have to download
an index config first. Alright. Okay. Which I'm
assuming is just this one here. So let's
copy this
and get a new tab.
I'm gonna call this index config dot YAML.
And all this is doing is configuring some
fields, so title body creation.
It's an RFC3239
for the dates.
And then we've got the precision sentence and
a second. I'm assuming we can change that
to
milliseconds,
nanoseconds.
What what's supported here under precision?
Yeah.
So
so so so we store,
like,
we we you have different storage here because
it's it's written fast precision, and it's
so we need you need to understand that
you have different storage parked in Quickwit.
So there is the document storage where we
store, like, the data as it is given,
or there is an option to ignore and
not store in the docs documents. Sorry. So
it's it's a kind of host store. So
if you have a document ID, we will
be able to fetch, like, the old document
from from
the the database.
And
then we have also columnar storage, but we
can we we call that fast fields.
Mhmm. And in this case,
depending on your data, you don't it's not
necessary to
to keep, like, the nanosecond precision, for example.
And being
at seconds level, it can be sufficient
if you just want to filter by
seconds.
So it depends on your use use case.
Generally, for upsides the use case, we use
milliseconds per sessions.
Okay.
Nice.
I see that we're using the default tokenizer
for the title and the body.
What other tokenizers exist within Quickwit?
Yeah. So the default tokenizer is
rather simple, and it it's mainly
for log stuff.
Mhmm.
And what you will do, we just split,
like, every time it enters a space or
comma or, like, a punctuation mark.
It will just split the text.
You can you you have an English tokenizer
where you have some stemming.
You have also some
we have a multilanguage
tokenizer too.
You
have an tokenizer.
You have a a bunch of of tokenizer.
You can come you can also build your
own tokenizer your own tokenizer if you want.
And for logs and, generally, you don't want
to make things complex. You want to keep
things very, very simple, so to be fast
at indexing.
Alright.
Let's get us an index then. So
let's copy this. So that's it's just using
the Quickwit command, but there is a current
post issue, which is cool.
So let's just run.
Oh, I'm not in my directory.
Alright. Let's do this split. That keeps me
in my directory.
Now where did I put that fail though?
That's a good question.
Cool.
Alright.
So we're going to ask Quickwit to create
our new index using this config.
Let's jump back to the user interface,
And now we have our stack overflow index.
Nice.
So this this now has like, I did
notice on our YAML that we applied, we
didn't set the mode. So the default mode
is dynamic, but you can you can set
it to strict.
So
I'm I'm I'm very curious now because now
that we have an index,
if I come in and change the index,
can I reapply it over the top?
Currently, we don't support updates.
Okay.
So it's
it's on the road map, but you
have to to delete it right now.
I well, I I I don't need to.
I was just curious because I like to
ask questions. But I'm assuming if we
remove the title in the body because the
default mode is dynamic, I could apply this,
and it would essentially be the same. Is
that a fair assumption?
So you need to understand, like, the default
settings
of a dynamic mode. And the dynamic mode,
we want to organize the text
by default.
Right. So that's why, like,
usually, what we do when you you identify,
like, the few the
fields where you need to
to
tokenize the text, and then everything else is
is dynamic.
Okay. Yeah. I guess that definitely makes sense.
So
alright. Now we're gonna add some documents.
let's download our
Stack Overflow post.
And I won't bother looking at this JSON.
Let's just get it ingested right away.
What's the force for here? Out of curiosity.
Yeah.
Like, as
it has we have the same mechanism as
in Elasticsearch is, generally, if you want to
be facet indexing, you have to batch things.
So
batching, like, you can wait twenty seconds or
thirty seconds before really committing and writing the
data structure on the disk.
For this index, by default, it's ten seconds.
Like, we commit every ten seconds. It can
be five seconds, but under, you will see
some
performance.
It will be less performance, basically. And so
here, force is just saying to Quickwit. Okay.
Just commit
immediately
so you can search
it immediately.
Nice. You don't have to wait ten seconds.
Alright.
Let's
try
throwing this reject here
When we get documents back.
Very cool.
I'm assuming I could just replicate that search
on our
user interface. So let's pull this up.
Search
and
engine.
Run.
Nice. I like it.
So that it's even things are just simple.
It just work. It's like it's just nice.
It's nice that that's all I have to
do.
Very cool.
Alright. Let's see. So
and I want us to understand
that we can okay. So this is now
getting into how to use
fields type searches. This is explicitly looking on
the title.
So let's look at this one here.
Yes. I assume there is an interesting question
for from
a
some from Blackmob band.
Sorry?
There is an I I saw that there
is an into
interesting question for Blackmob.
Right. Was too busy to play with Quickwit.
Alright. Let's see.
Okay. From a cost perspective,
it seems like traces and logs play a
special role. Is this actually the case?
Yeah. Sure. Like, he's right. So
it's and, like, the the the basic example
is to is that Quickwit has some OpenTelemetry
compatibility.
Like, we
gRPC
we we we are compatible Quickwit is compatible
with gRPC
open telemetry app API, HTTP API too. So
it's really easy to send your logs directly
into it. And I I would talk about
it
in my demo, so
I don't don't want to talk too much
of a right now.
Yeah.
So I think, you know, based on some
of the things we've covered so far, and
I don't wanna put words in your mouth
for anything like that. Right? But we did
talk about how the use cases at the
start.
I don't know. And I and I said,
are there more beyond the observability use case?
Like, from what I've seen so far, I
mean, if I really wanted to, I could
throw the entire IMDB database into this and
search for movies and actors, and it would
work just fine
based on what I wanna do. So
it's just one of those
yeah. It's a search engine where you're just
you're focusing on a particular use case, but
it does adapt very well, I think, to
other use cases. Would you agree with that?
Yep. Alright. Of course.
Now there's a challenge here already,
and I don't know if this is part
of the dogs or not. Right? But we
have title body creation date,
and there's no title or question
in these imports.
That's true.
That's fair. That's So I mean, the next
stage was to do a title and that
this should return.
Oh, it did get one.
One question had it. Yeah.
Oh, because you I I guess some documents
don't have titles,
I guess. That's it. Okay. Oh, okay. Right.
So now I don't want to find this,
but I wanna find that question another way.
So I'm gonna switch to body
and this time we will do a n
t l r just because I see that
on the thing. Oh, we got three questions.
K. Cool.
With this being the first one
and then this one.
Would this also work for
integers? So if I do one six nine
three.
Yeah.
Cool.
Very nice.
Let's see if user
one zero one has answered more than one
question.
Yeah.
Alright. I'm having fun here. This is nice.
So okay. So we executed a query and
all of this could be done with Carl,
with a JSON payload. That makes sense.
I'm curious. Can I
if I come here, let's say I wanna
create an index?
Can I just submit from here? Is it,
like, one of those? No. Okay. It just
shows me. K.
You can Oh, yeah. I can. Yeah. I'm
not using it, but I I
people
use use that.
I'm only using this to discover the endpoints
and then that's it.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's create an index this way. I
I don't know. I just I like pushing
buttons and see what happens.
And this does have an override flag, actually.
Or maybe I can update or maybe it's
not an update. Does it do a delete
and a create?
That's a good question. So here, I'll write
let me think of it. So it creates
an index.
Yeah. Exactly. So it would it would just
delete the previous one before creating. So
that's it.
Okay. So let's create an index
where I can see the mapping.
We've got a modal lenient. I'm not sure
how that's different from dynamic, but maybe we
could talk about that. This one is using
the multiline tokenizer
and index.
Okay. So I have to fill in some
of these. Let's just call this
Rawkode.
I mean, I guess this isn't actually a
valid document. Right? I'd have to change quite
a bit here. Yeah. What what you can
do is just drop almost everything. Keep the
if you really want to to do it,
the best would be dropping, like, most of
the part.
I think what I'll I'll just copy this
one and make a few tweaks. Like, I
don't actually need to
Oh, wait. This is no YAML.
Maybe you can change, like, the request body
type. Maybe you can change application to
this is there is a
Ah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So it's it's it's not available. Right?
So let's let's K. Good good luck with
that.
There isn't an application YAML, though, is there?
Either maybe there is.
Maybe, like, text YAML or something.
Let's just try and break it. What's the
worst that can happen? Right?
So we already have
Stack Overflow, so we'll call this Rawkode.
And Will it work?
Okay.
It is generating, yes, for bad stuff. Right?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
But it has given me the curl command,
so I could adapt the content type that
way. But it's it's not important. I just
I see something. I need to click it
or play with it. So
alright.
So now we could delete our index
like so.
Run this.
Let's see. Yes.
And then we get a t l d
r with the commands and stuff like that.
So that
this is really cool. It's super easy to
work with. We got an issue added to
the search.
All the API documentation is embedded into the
UI, which is awesome.
I mean, really, for anyone watching this, it's
like, that's interesting. I wanna play with it.
You've made it super simple, and that's fantastic.
So good job. Quickwit team. Thank you.
Now
there's obviously
a whole bunch of configuration.
There's clustering that's available.
I think you're gonna be doing the data
with doing a demo with slightly more data,
which is really cool.
We already talked about deployments. You're gonna show
the Kubernetes one.
So I guess the last question from my
side before we kinda talk about your demo
and, actually, I'll just move it back to
to back base mode.
What what is the
how does the clustering work with Quickwit? Are
you using, like, you know, Raft to do
a consensus? Are you doing something completely different?
Maybe you could share a bit more details.
Yeah. Okay. Well, that's an interesting question.
Raft, like, it's always, like, painful to do
to do these kind of things. So we
we avoided that for now.
We don't like
we managed to
scale the Quickwit cluster to
fifty
fifth between 5,100
nodes and in ingesting more than, like,
several gigabytes per seconds,
and it was it's working well. So right
now, we don't need that. We may need
one
later
for
replicating the metastore.
So currently,
let me so we don't use Rawkode at
all.
The cluster formation is ensured by
a gossip algorithm
that we implemented
called Chinchot.
Mhmm.
So
so once the cluster is is is formed,
so you have different roles.
You have, like, the metastable,
which is
the central piece where we store the index
config,
the splits metadata so that we we are
for an index, we are aware well, how
many splits we have, how many documents in
those splits,
and a few bunch of meta metadata. This
is very small because, generally, you have for
10,000,000 documents, you have one split. So it's
pretty, pretty small.
And you can choose to host it to
host this to to to back this metastore
component
by
a file on an object store or PostgresQL.
So once you have this metastore, then you
have
search of roles and
indexer role.
And thanks to the decouple architecture,
like, you know that your data is on
your object storage, for example.
And you can start one or 10 searches,
and they all fetch data from the object
storage.
That's for the read part.
And on the right path,
you will have those indexes who will receive
some documents through the ingest API or from
a Kafka source or Kinesis or Google Pepsis,
whatever. We have we have native integrations with
several
distributed queues.
And those indexes
will just prove the data from Kafka or
will just take the data that you send
in through the ingest API,
write
index files, split files on the disk, and
upload them to the object storage.
And that's it for
currently, it's working. It's it is scaling parallel
like this, and you have
totally different write and read pass,
which makes it very simple to manage.
You have
a a last component called that
is doing
very
a few things only.
Typically, it is handling the retention
stuff. So if you every hour, I would
it would he he the janitor will check
if he can delete some speed files on
the object storage.
And it can also execute some delete request
because we have users who
may
want for g GDPR
reasons.
They want to delete some data in
in their index. So it's possible to delete
data in the in Quickwit, but not
at a frequent rate. So Quickwit is not
made
for updates typically.
But for infrequent deletes, it's working
it's working well, and the generator is ensuring
this part.
And that's it for the for the architecture.
Yeah. Okay. So that
delete constraint is why
append only
data, like logs and observability is why it's
such a good use case for that, and
that's why you're pushing on that. So that
makes sense.
Now the blobs, the objects store stuff, right,
for your
meta store and for all the data itself,
Do you support, like, tiered storage? Like, can
I keep the last six hours of logs
and traces on a fast NVMe disk
and then push everything older to object store,
or is that something that may come later?
So,
yeah, object storage is our primary site.
So it's not the it's it's the primary
store. Right. Okay. So that's the first thing.
Now
if you have a lot of queries,
you may want to use some caching.
And it's we so we added this feature
in the last version of Quickwit.
So what will happen is that on the
searcher side, only on the read pass because
it's where you have your queries coming in
and you have to respond super fast, for
example, or you have a lot of QPS.
In this case,
you want to keep on your local disk
the data that you already downloaded, for example.
So those
split files, you want to keep there keep
keep it there.
So we added this possibility to to reduce
the cost of the object store storage because,
as you know, you when you
with a storage like s three, you will
pay the get request.
And
this will
this can become pricey if you have a
lot of.
K.
Awesome.
Alright. Are you ready
for your big skiddy demo? Yeah. Sure.
Alright. So just preparing my screen.
Yeah. Take your time, man. All good.
Okay. I'm I will share my entire screen.
Let's go.
I'm just checking if
I can connect. So so
here, I'm
I'm
I'm showing you a quick the Quickwit interface
on the cluster that is
available
on
on the Google Kubernetes engine.
So it is hosted on Google Cloud.
What can I show you?
So we I have a bunch of node
here.
So contrary to the
Quickstart,
here we are we we have a cluster
deployed with a hand chart,
and we have, like,
several nodes with different
different role roles, and I forgot to talk
about the control plane,
which is quite important,
actually.
So the control plane here, I will explain
it in
a a few seconds.
It is handling,
like, how we distribute the indexing task to
indexes.
So it will look at
all the indexes you have, and we say,
okay. This indexer will handle those 100 indexes,
and
this second indexer will handle those two those
10 indexes those 10 remaining indexes.
You have one searcher node, one indexer here,
the generator, and the.
You have also dead nodes because
previously,
before
this
this demo, I
started
10 nodes on this cluster, and they are
all dead right now because I shut them
down.
So, yeah, also on this cluster, I have
a bunch of
indexes.
I will show you during this demo the
trace indexes because I will ingest a lot
of trace in in it.
I already inserted
almost 300
millions of traces. So it's not traces. Actually,
it's spans.
When you when you collect
when you
when you instrument your applications, your application will
send span. So
you need operation
in
in your program.
There are there are, like, 65 splits,
and it's it's represents
in a very compressed size is 200
gigabytes,
and Quickwit managed to compress it to 35
gigabytes.
And it's on
it's not on s three, but it's on
Google Cloud Storage. So we are compatible with
different
different object storage.
Nice.
So
one interesting thing
I can show you, like, the the query
detail. So so here, I have only
okay. I have also logs here. So I
I will show you in. But
I have only one searcher, and so I'm
able to search,
like,
inside millions of
millions of spans.
So in two seconds here because
I'm searching through all the documents, so it's
not very efficient.
But I can just for example, let me
choose
probably yes.
Searching through only the service
name Quickwit
because on this cluster, I'm
indexing
Quickwit on traces.
So the fact here, I'm just looking into
1,000,000
1,700,000
spans, and it's way faster. Mhmm.
And everything is on object size. But
for Quickwit, it's it's not it's not a
big dataset here. If you have 200 millions,
that's okay. That's really
easy to handle. So what I will do
is we will index more more that into
it. And I will also show you
our graph on that plug in because we
implemented, like,
a graph on that plug in to
to search through logs and traces.
So what I will do now is that
I will I will start indexing
data into Quickwit a bit more than
currently.
So here,
what you see is a dashboard to monitor
Quickwit
with metrics.
You have, like, the classic endpoint slash metrics
to gather metrics generated by Quickwit.
So here, I'm looking at
the in the indexing
throughput of hotel traces index.
And you can see that you have already
a bunch of documents that are indexed.
Those spikes are due to the fact that
I ran some queries. And so when you
run queries on Quickwit, it will generate more
logs, and that's why there is more more
spans here.
But but it's almost nothing. So what I
will do
is I will
use a tool called.
So this
so
is a tool is a tool
that allows you to generate a lot of
spans and
send them
to one sync that is compatible with your
open telemetry
protocol.
So for example, here, I will generate I
will just create
jobs
several jobs that are sending
spans
to Quickwit.
So here, I'm using the OpenTelemetry
API of Quickwit.
So you are seeing that Quickwit has indexer
service,
and we will send just boost tray boost
traces to the indexer service. And then the
indexer service, if you have several indexers, it
will just forward those spans to
whatever indexer
are present.
So right now, we have only
one indexer,
and I would just create
this first job.
Fraction.
I'm gonna check if
everything needs I started. So okay. We have,
like, those different jobs that are created,
and they they will send, like, thousands of
spans to Quickwit.
Let's
see how Quickwit responds on this.
K. So you you see this this spike.
So, normally, you you should expect Quickwit to
index
at between 20 megabytes per second and
40 megabytes per second.
For for very simple documents,
you can go up to 40 megabytes. So
here, we should expect something around 30 megabytes
per second,
and we will see how which kind of
spans are sent by.
So yeah. So we have this
this first indexer that is running, so we're
happy with it. But
if we if you want to index more
data,
what we can do is scale the indexer.
So
in Quickwit, you have
in the deployment, the hand chart that we
provide.
We we added two stateful sets for indexer
and searcher.
And I'm using here the common line tool
or k nine that is very, very cool
to play with Kubernetes.
And I will just
add nine more indexers to
to index more data.
So,
normally
Yeah. So
I added, like, nine indexers, and they're they're
already ready.
So I'm normally, I should be able to
start another job that is sending even more
traces, and I have a second job
Second job for that.
This one has even more jobs, and
we
it will send more traces to Quickwit.
So let's create it
and see what's happening on Quickwit side.
But here, we have those two indexes
from the metric. I will just refresh just
to make sure that we are taking into
account
all the pods that are running.
And we will wait a bit to see
how indexing is scaling.
Okay. So
here, you you can see that we are
already at 162
megabytes per second.
I will jump to
the graph and I plug in interface of
Quickwit so
that we can we can have a look
at the volume.
Can I ask a question? Yep. Sure. Can
go you go back to that index and
dashboard?
Yep. So something I noticed that was quite
interesting there is the
resident set size of indexer zero dropped.
Is it rebalancing
across the other nine
indexers?
So probably here I I don't know what
why he did that. Why
Normally,
what's when you will see such a drop,
it's just that it is indexing less documents.
And so
the indexer is taking so probably,
some documents went to another indexer.
That's the most probable thing.
So
even though the data is stored in object
store, did the indexer store everything in RAM,
or are they paging it in and out?
Yeah. So one one
indexer has, like it needs to it needs
some RAM to build the the data structure.
And we have
what we call a wall so that to
that is saved on the disk
So that when you restart, it will
if you if you have, like,
an issue on your on
on your pod, it will all start with
at the same position.
So it will keep, like, a buffer here.
It's I think it's twenty seconds for this
index
before it is uploaded to
to the object storage.
So the this time is used for the
wall and for building the the data structure
the index data structure. Yeah. So that drop
then may it's just been a flush in
the wall to object store potentially.
Yeah. And, also, what
I would expect is that it isn't this
particular node
is indexing less document than others. If it's
lower, like, we can check.
For example,
if we look at the first one, because
this is the first one.
So we can see that it's indexing only
on 20 megabytes.
And
let's have a look at another one. This
one is indexing more. So
what I suspect
is that the configuration of is a lit
little bit different for
the first job.
I don't know. I'm I'm not I'm not
sure here.
Let me check.
Let's see. The configuration seems
I don't know. No. It's I I don't
think it's coming oh, that's interesting. Here, we
are using gRPC, and here we are using
Uh-huh. HTTP endpoint.
So there is a this small difference.
Okay.
Okay. May maybe I I should look into
that to see if it's coming from from
that, or maybe it's the
node that is already running
the jobs
from
from.
I'm not sure. Yeah. Okay. Thanks.
Okay. So
nice thing is that you can see that
we are indexing a lot of traces,
and you
what now we want to search to to
have a look at this volume too, and
that's the nice thing that we have. So
I'm using here the
Quickwit
plugin.
And
so it's like
we
it's a that
you can use, like, any other
plugging.
Actually, I'm not on the right.
I think I should be there. Yes.
Because I have two I have two instances.
So one on port three three thousand.
So I must
stay on this one.
So for this demo, I created two
two data source, one for logs and one
for traces.
To create
a Quickwit data source, you have to specify
the HTTP endpoint. So here,
we we are just pointing pointing to the
Quickwit searcher service.
And then you have to specify
an index ID.
The message field name, log level field name
are optional.
You can also link to
trace ID, and I will show you what's
the purpose of that. It is when you
want to go from, like, a log line
or a document and see
the whole traces
the whole trace with all the spans and
show it with with
with
user interface.
So let's go back to the explore view
and have a look at traces.
So here, we have some logs because I'm
I'm using OpenTelemetry
collector to send logs into Quickwit.
So it's a classic setup for a Kubernetes
cluster.
But let's have a look at traces.
So here we have
one searcher,
but we have a lot of logs. So
that's why it is taking some time.
And, actually, I will probably reduce the number.
I will stop
I will stop this because
the index would be a bit too too
large. I don't want to
we
we we can support this, but I think
it's it's useless
now.
So okay. It is taking a bit longer
than I would expect.
So sometimes I have some issues with my
with my instance.
So I have some packets over at all
lost. So I would just
restart this
portal one to make sure that
it it's working.
So we have already, like,
several hundreds and of millions of traces. So
we have only one searcher that is fetching
data directly from the pure object storage,
and
we are doing here two query.
Two queries. One query is for it's a
data.
You you have to so it is taking,
like, several seconds,
but you have to see that here we
are
making an aggregation over
probably now
let's let's have a look at this.
Yes. We we have almost
millions of documents.
So it's normal with one searcher to
to take a few few seconds to just
do this data histogram. In one minute here,
you can see that we have 27,000,000
spans, so that's a lot.
But Quickwit can handle it with only one
searcher. And, of course, if you look at
the only
fifty minutes, it should be faster.
But you you still have a lot. Yeah.
So here we are looking at traces,
spans to
be
accurate.
So if we look at a a span,
this one is a Quickwit span, like service
name Quickwit.
So if if
I'm looking so I can play with this
and search for span like this.
So
if I'm looking only at quick quickwit service
service,
you have a lot less
faces spans because most of them are generated
by trash
gen.
Something like that.
So, yeah, so here, we have
we have all of your we our traces
on traces
job.
And if we look at Quickwit, what can
be interesting is that if you look. So
here, the interface is not very nice,
but we can have a look at the
what's inside the span
and also
link it to
the trace.
So here, for example, it's a trace it's
a search trace from Quickwit.
So you can
really
see what's
happening inside Quickwit.
So here we have a leaf search. So
leaf, it's because it's happening on one
one node, and we are searching through one
single split.
And then you have the those different steps.
So you you can dig into that.
Can I ask a question? Yep.
Is on the right hand side, right, the
split the split to show the trace, is
that actually creating Quickwit, or is it creating
Jaeger?
Okay. It's here. It's create we are I'm
using a Yeager
data source.
Mhmm. And it is this Yeager data source
is directly hitting
the rest API of Quickwit to gather the
spans
here. Okay. So you support
the Yeager API for the benefits of this
Grafana plugin and other UIs, I guess. But
Yeah. Exactly. So I
just showing you how I configured, like, for
Yeager data source. So data source I like
that.
Is just so you have to
to give, like, the standpoint.
And because
plug in is using the rest API, which
is covering, like, spans in a certain way,
and we implemented it we implemented it
at the end point.
And that's it.
What else? So one interesting thing that you
can do
with Quickwit is also aggregations.
What else can I show you? For example,
here, if we look for
traces,
one thing that you
that is nice to do with traces
so I will look at Quickwit traces because
they are more relevant than try the problem
with is
that they are a bit dumb.
I will show you some of them a
bit later.
But one thing that you can do with
Quickwit is
do some analytics
on your traces. So for example,
if you want to do,
like, some kind of term aggregation
on span name,
that's typically what you want to do.
And what you want to do is to
to know if which span is, for example,
taking longer
than you than it should. In this case,
you can have a look at the average,
for example, of the span duration.
So here,
we have the output of an aggregation that
is giving us, like, all the spans that
are available
on the Quickwit service
and, like, the average
duration of each span.
So it can give you, like, a good
idea.
Generally,
we want to
get the percentile.
Monitor, like, when you monitor a service,
it's it's nice. So you can you can
get the the percentile
to to see there is a degradation in
your service.
And I will I will assure you a
real a well world application monitoring just after
that.
So yeah. So
you can do this, like,
on really on really big datasets.
So that that's that's one of the
advantage of using Quickwit.
And So how how much of
Lucene's
search
and operators do you support?
Because right now, we've we've been doing very
basic searches. Right? We haven't done any term
boosting, fuzzy matching.
Yeah.
And does it support any of that stuff?
Yeah. So it supports
what we support currently
okay. We don't support the fuzzy part. We
support prefix
queries.
So
here, if I'm starting, like, quick with an
AMD ending
this with a star, it will
return the response.
We don't support suffix suffix query where you
would start with the star.
So fuzzy fuzzy
query does not work.
We don't support currently even
if, like, we we could because it's fuzzy
and queries are supported in.
So we could add it.
What
the issue what we have with this kind
of queries is that you would we need
to cache more things. So we don't
we did for for now, we we don't
we did not added it added to to
Quickwit.
So, yeah, currently,
what you can do is this kind of
stuff, like,
for example, if you want to
specify a span name
You can do this Boolean queries.
Yeah. That that's mostly the the the main
part that you can you can do. You
can do some phrase query
on the full text search. What I I
can show you probably
this on the Quickwit log index.
So here we have logs, so you have
more
text. So it's nice to
to have a look at this.
Let me find, like, this.
Would you be able to do a sorry.
I'm gonna sort of span out of work.
Yeah. We have some nested JSON there with
the resource attributes. So would you be able
to find
logs where
the namespace or node name is that JSON
value?
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So that that's one
like, everything that is
not
declared in the schema or declared you can
you can do this kind of
fancy stuff. So you can you you can
write this. Oh, great. Okay.
Oh, so it just expands that out for
you when that JSON artifact exists on the
payload. Yes. So it's
the Quickwit
the Quickwit plug in is expanding this. So
it's
so the the region is there, so you
can have it. That's a that's a real
document.
And then it's is exploded for
UI
reasons. Okay. Cool.
So
what you can do, but
not not on this index because
it's not possible as I with I don't
index positions for logs, but you can do
fresh queries also. So for example,
imagine,
like, if we take, for example, this message,
like, merge.
You you
if you want to match exactly
those two consecutive words,
like, it's in body message.
But you you won't be happy because I
did not index the positions. But
for for some use cases, it's nice to
be able to do phrase queries.
When I say phrase queries, it is that
we expect a document to
documents only with those two consecutive words. Nothing
between them.
And we have, like, with
slope.
Slope, it means that we tolerate, like,
a change of positions of one
element,
and and that's it. So we we we
support those kind of queries too. But generally
for calls them proximity queries. Right? Or you
want two words within four words of of
each other? In Elasticsearch world, it's
phrase queries with slope, I think. Oh, alright.
Okay.
Great. So current it's not working here because
I have said
we I did not index, like,
the the positions.
For logs, generally, it's not necessary.
Okay. Cool.
Awesome. Yeah.
So
I think that's it for the demo that
I can show you today.
I have, like, a preview of what you
can expect in the
in the coming
weeks or months.
Because here, one drawback here, as you I
think you you will note you noticed it,
is that it's
it's nice to be able to search through,
like, this amount of logs. It's nice to
be able to to to build this kind
of statistics.
But you can you can
go you can do more.
And I prepared, like,
an application monitoring dashboard built with Quickwit.
So here, you can imagine that you have
an application.
Like, here, it's a first API
application,
and I'm running,
like, on my local instance,
some script
that is making request
on this API.
And
this application this past API application is also
instrumented with
OpenTelemetry,
and it is sending traces to Quickwit.
And so what I did here is
saw a bunch of aggregations with what's available
with Quickwit currently.
And I just, like as I showed
you the latency of
span name before,
Here, I'm just showing you the average latency
of some service name.
And
here, I'm using
a span attributes,
not
not a HTTP content length, but here we
are we are looking for the the root.
So if you you look at the root,
you can, like, build
your application monitoring dashboard
because
OpenTelemetry
giving is giving you, like, the nice attributes
that you can use
to understand what's happening in your application.
Nice.
So
here it's a it's a preview because currently,
I'm still working on this.
It's working I'm using the zero dot seven
version, so it's you can already
do that with with Quickwit.
I'm just not
totally satisfied by
when you need to compute some
rates.
Like,
Quickwit is nice for computing
percentage,
average,
mean, max,
this class boost classic statistics.
But we are new not good at
computing
rates
rates, for example, which is more classic when
you when you are doing some time series
analysis.
So we hope to provide with those kind
of aggregations
in the coming months
and so to have a to to be
able to
to build even better dashboard than this one.
And
that's that's our road map currently, so we
want to to provide this kind of stuff.
What else?
Yeah. We one thing that we want to
work on is also
the
plugin as you saw it in the explore
view.
Here, when you need to build your query,
it's
you you need to you you need to
your to know your mapping. So it's not
always easy
to know which field to query,
so we plan to improve this experience.
And we have a bunch of developments that
are
but we we are currently working on it
to improve
globally the plugin experience.
So we hope to to deliver more things
on on the user interface side.
And on the back end side,
we plan to work also on on metrics,
which are not supported currently in Quickwit
and also to provide a type query language.
So we we are we have a lot
of work for this for this year.
Yeah.
There's a question
that we have from Blackboard Ben asking,
is it oh, I'll pop this back over
here just there we go. Is it possible
to parse log bodies at query time to
support cases where log records weren't properly parsed
at ingestion time? So, you know, where we
have that JSON inside of the source of
the body that hasn't been expanded or exploded
is their ability to do that.
Like, you know, the way I don't know
if you're familiar with locating and LogQL, but
it has the ability to pipe into a
parse JSON and then start to query and
work with that JSON. Is that something Quickwit
would have on a short map?
So
I'm just trying to understand
what what do you want to do to
do do you want to do some, like,
some
count on it, some aggregation on it? Like,
you I'm not sure to understand the the
use case. Yeah. Maybe there's a log client
that has adjacent string
where they want to parse that and filter
based on one of the properties within the
JSON and then aggregate that. Yeah. Okay. So
we we we do we do not support
that currently.
K. Is that something that you're looking to
support in the future, or are you just
focusing purely on on metrics at the moment?
That's a good question. Like,
currently, don't know what we will support on
this part. Mhmm.
What what we want to provide is a
a pipeline wage so that you can indeed
filter on whatever field you want, then pipe
it and count and then pipe it again
and do some stuff. I don't know yet
exactly what we will do. That's all. That's
the plan, but I don't have details.
Do you think you'd be likely to support
LogQL
rather than inventing your own?
Yeah. That's
one of the question we have. Like, I
think we want to, like,
we want to support to be well integrated
in the ecosystem.
So
we plan to support
Kibana,
and
we also we support,
obviously,
Kafana.
So we really want to
it's actually
being compatible with existing language could be really
nice.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, thank you so much for joining us
today, for sharing all the information about Quickwit
and for the wonderful demo.
I was getting a little bit nervous with
the how much data you were putting through
it, but Quickwit handled it just fine. So
that was awesome. Yeah. And usually,
start several searches, but
I need to start several searches when you
have billions of documents.
Like, 500
millions, that's okay. Child's
play.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you again.
Thank you very much. Anyone watching after the
fact, please feel free to add any comments
that you have or questions to the comment
section, and we'll do our best to get
back to you as soon as we can.
And Blackboard, Ben, says thank you, folks. Yeah.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you, Francois, and everyone have a wonderful
day. Bye. Thank